some people are wondering how this guy
just became the president of Argentina
American Media are saying a right-wing
Argentinian Trump just took power but
Trump believes in big government mle
wants to disband Argentina's Central
Bank and take a chainsaw to the state
how this wild-haired libertarian who
believes in Austrian economics become
president well the 40% poverty rate for
one and the rampant inflation for
another you thought your groceries got
expensive imagine living under triple
digit inflation and now imagine your
choices were the chainsaw guy who rants
about
leftists or the economic Minister from
the ruling party that got you into this
situation to begin with what would you
do Javier Malay is what happens when the
government devalues your money Torpedoes
your economy and corrupts your
institutions we don't know if Malay will
succeed in fixing Argentina's economy
but there's a lesson here for American
politicians at some point Reckless
spending and trampling on citizens
Liberties can make the wild haired
libertarian look like the less crazy
option